cette vidéo est sponsorisée par rise of
Kingdom rise of Kingdom est le jeu de
stratégie au 100 millions de
téléchargements basés sur l'histoire
avec 13 civilisation construisez des
villes avec leur architecture unique sur
une carte commune contenant tous les
stratèges du monde choisissez un
commandant avec des aptitudes unique et
jouer Cléopâtre à la tête de son armée
de tribuché qui repousse les hordes de
chevaliers totonique waouh mais ce jeu
est un véritable cours d'histoire
bonjour je suis prof de math et je
confirme aussi sûr que deux et deux font
et en plus la version PC vient de sortir
avec une jouabilité fluide et des
commandes de RTS classi por rise of
Kingdom un tout autre niveau et grâce à
la fonction crossplay vous pouvez
détruire vos adversaire depuis votre
appareil préféré rejoignez ou quittez
une bataille en un instant ch pendant
que vous jouez la version PC r tout cela
si facile enfin je suis plus obligé de
traler mon téléphone
partout
améliorez vos capacités grâce à un arbre
de talent unique et un système de
compéten de style RPG établissez vos
stratégies forgez des alliances et
partez raser les villes de vos voisins
dans le jeu dans le jeu pitié juste dans
le jeu essayez gratuitement la version
PC de Rise of Kingdom ou la version
mobile avec le lien en description et le
QR code à l'écran n'oubliez pas le code
playrock for PC pour des récompenses en
jeu
bah alors pourquoi tu es assis par terre
il est où ton
canapé ah c'est une longue histoire je
vais t'expliquer
hein salut à tous nouvelle saison et
nouvel épisode de Joueur du Grenier et
tu as pasette bonnes vacances Seb non
pas terrible je me suis entraîné à faire
des plâtres et c'est pas si marrant que
ça et aujourd'hui est un grand jour un
double grand jour même puisque je sais
que vous attendez depuis longtemps la
vidéo 10 numéro 2 mais le problème c'est
que bah les jeux Disney ils sont pas si
mauvais que ça et en même temps j'ai
quand même envie de vous en parler donc
et ben vous savez quoi je pense qu'il
est temps aujourd'hui d'évoluer dans la
formule Joueur du
Grenier j'ai joué à BBS 3D et c'était à
chier j'ai eu un cancer du cul avec les
tortues ma vie était un
calvaire avec Dragon slir ce jeu des
enfers nique ta
mère je change de chemin le prochain
test sera un vrai bon
jeu je regarde toujours vers demain vous
êtes les bienvenus dans la Disney
2 ah ouis ah
[Musique]
ou qu'est-ce que c'est que je là c'est
pas du tout des trucs Disney ça non mais
regarde un jeu Cendrillon dégueulasse là
Blancheneige et les se garçons
intelligents le Lion et le roi Hercule
avec un K je comprends pas je l'ai pris
au même endroit que
[Musique]
d'habitude ouais bon de toute façon j'y
croyais pas moi-même à cette chanson
cassez-vous les fille c'est bon on a
plus besoin de
[Musique]
vous
connard 1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh oh qu'est-ce que c'est que ce
truc là on dirait qu'ils ont maquillé le
cadavre d'une adolescente pour faire
croire qu'elle est encore un peu vivante
regarde son regard regarde même pas vers
la pomme elle a le regard dans le vide
en dehors de la jaquette et pourquoi la
sorcière là on dirait vol de morort à
qui on aurait écrasé la gueule ils ont
mis des images de vrais sapins avec une
vraie image de lune mais par contre les
nains on dir qu'ils ont été fait par un
collégien qui découvre la 3D pendant son
stage
là alors le texte blancheeneige vit au
plus profond d'une forêt parfaite vie
avec
cette attends vie au profond attends 2
secondes vie au plus profond d'une forêt
parfaite vie mais il y a un vie trop là
il y a une faute littéralement dans les
10 premiers mots de la jaquette ah oui
oui d'accord oui ça va être un de de ces
trucs là en fait où c'est juste un film
avec des minijeux bon bah ok bah tant
pis allons-y hein W W W W attendez une
[Musique]
secondes ok donc je résume non seulement
il y a une faute d'orthographe dès la
première ligne à l'arrière de la boîte
mais en plus la Blanche Neige de la
jaquette n'a absolument rien à voir avec
la Blanche Neige qui est contenu dans le
CD du
[Musique]
jeu bon ben on va pas passer 1000 an sur
le film un habile mélange de PL en 3D et
en 2D horrible en 3 FPS sur fond de
trucs qui ont clairement été fait sous
Paint mais ça c'est du paint je
vous jure je vous jure que c'est du
paint c'est fou ce truc fait 6 minutes
ça a dû leur coûter je sais pas 100
balles et 3 sandwich et même avec ça ils
ont essayé de faire des économies
d'animation monsieur on a pas asse
d'animation avant le début de la
chanson je sais pas fait une
boucle
[Musique]
c'est pas mal ou ouais c'est pas mal
ouais la VO quant à elle a été faite
avec toute la conviction de mec qui
n'est pas français ni formé ni payé pour
le faire et je soupçonne même qu'elle a
été enregistrée avant la vidéo il yitbi
quiembl à untit alors non pas du tout
mais déjà pourquoi blanchenige les
clever boys même la voix dans la vidéo
dit que c'est
c'est peut-être pour pas choquer les
petites personnes enfin je veux dire les
traités de nain c'est considéré comme
choquant
[Musique]
non as raison c'est sement pour pas
choquer quant à l'histoire et bien c'est
l'histoire de se petit garçons normau
qui vivent dans une forêt et font des
trucs de garçons normau du genre faire
du skate à la
verticalef alors quee la compag de boys
rentrent chez eux ils découvrent la
porte grande ouverte qui cela peut-il
être oh et il y a un visage amusant sur
la cheminée regarde et il y a de la
fumée qu'est-ce qui se passe
ok je je sais que je devrais pas
chercher à rationaliser quelque chose
qui est visiblement clairement fait pour
des enfants un petit peu débiles mais
pourquoi la voix off souligne ça ça veut
dire quoi que c'est pas normal que les
objets soient vivants dans ce monde
parce qu'on en reparle plus jamais après
mais les objets qui prennent vie c'est
une information je importante quand même
non ah regardez la porte de la maison
est ouverte et il y a un portail
dimensionnel avec Satan qui sort mais
quand même la porte est ouverte
bref à l'intérieur Blancheneige est
rentré chez eux pour squatter comme une
putaine sans abri mais visiblement tout
le monde s'en fout bon en même temps on
va pas trop leur demander vu qu'ils ont
préféré téléporter les personnages pour
éviter d'animer une porte qui s'ouvre et
qu'ils arrivent de toute façon pas à
passer d'une animation à l'autre sans
faire un de vieux fondu
dégueulasse d'ailleurs au passage un big
up au mec qui a écrit la chanson et qui
clairement n'était pas assez payé pour
écrire des ch l'uvre pareil
ouais enfin des paroles engagées je mets
des mots les un à la suite des autres en
plus cette chanson quand tu écoutes les
paroles elle est horrible
[Musique]
elle est JAL de moi parce que je suis
trop fraîche et elle c'est une grosse
bizarre le message pour les enfants
là bon évidemment blab bla bla il y a
une sorcière qui donne une pomme à
Blanche-Neige elle s'endort mais le
livreur ubert arrive et l'embrasse et
c'est fini voilà je pense qu'on a quand
même perdu une partie du message dans
cette adaptation et cette vidéo se
conclut par une charmante cérémonie dans
les bois Satan Satan Satan ok bon alors
niveau vidéo clairement Zelda CDI un
concurrent direct mais bon peut-être que
les mini jeux seront mieux donc alors
voyons voir qu'est-ce qu'on a des jeux
de mémoire ok aucun intérêt des puzzles
des puzzles avec une image animée
Z comme ça c'est bien chiant parce que
bah l'image change tout le temps super
idée comment vous pouvez rater un puzzle
c'est quelque chose qu'on arrive à faire
marcher littéralement sans électricité
mais ça va heureusement il y a aussi
dans ce jeu du coloriage une activité
que votre enfant peut faire
tranquillement et en
[Musique]
silence
cool et on trouve tout un tas de jeux
comme ça he Phenix c'est le nom de
l'éditeur était célèbre pour avoir
repompé tout un tas de Disney en en
faisant des mini jeux avec toujours le
même schéma un film pourri et des mini
jeux de merde à base de puzzle et de
coloriage on a déjà fait un jeu phenniix
dans un épisode et rappelez-vous
[Musique]
c'était passable et phenniix a chié des
dizaines de jeux dont une diarrhée
foudroyante en 2003 qui est l'année où
presque tous leurs jeux sont sortis avec
quasiment une sortie par semaine et on
va pas se le cacher la méthode de vente
chez Phoenix c'était simple c'était
d'arnaquer les parents donc forcément
leurs jeux les plus célèbres sont des
reprises de chez Disney à de doigts du
tribunal et on a toujours des jaquettes
qui ressemblent un peu à Disney mais
toujours en version un petit peu pourrie
quand même comme ça si tu es pressé que
tu as oublié le cadeau d'anniversaire de
ton gosse tu passes à toute vitesse dans
un magasin sur mal entendu ça peut
passer bon après il faut avoir oublié
ses lunettes aussi hein parce que il y a
certaines jaquettes c'est un peu chaud
genre ça qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
jaquette ma maman c'est ma sœur oh là là
et celle-là là dalmatien 2 ton chien il
a des moustaches de chat ils savent même
pas à quoi ça ressemble un chien bon
alors après des fois l'arnaque ça peut
passer hein genre la légende de Mulane
dinosaure bon là les jaquettes ça passe
à peu près mais par contre si tu t'es
fait avoir et que tu as acheté the toys
room à ton gosse en le confondant avec
Toy Story c'est vraiment que tu mérites
d'avoir un enfant malheureux d'ailleurs
si vous trouviez le dessai animé de
Blanche Neige moche vous n'avez
absolument rien vu puisque dans leurs
jeunes années la société phennix col
avec les Allemands de Dingo picture et
comme j'avais déjà parlé de leur film
dans un club JDG sur
Aladin les Dingo picture c'est du jus de
cauchemar
brut 100 % garanti votre enfant dormira
pas ce soir et même si j'ai très envie
de vous montrer ça et de vous faire
vivre ça parce que c'est vraiment
hypnotisant mais toi tu sais peut-être
où on peut trouver notre ami attends un
peu que je réfléchisse je vais te le
dire alors aucune idée bte et bien pour
la partie jeu vidéo c'est un petit peu
toujours la même chose he que ce soit
des puzzle ou des coloriage et ça
n'aurait pas grand intérêt de tous se
les
faire bon dis donc vous foutez pas de ma
gueule un peu là par hasard c'est quoi
ces jeux que vous avez vendu là je vois
pas le problème je vous ai demandé des
jeux Disney vous me prandz ces merdes si
êtes pas content vous avez qu'Al la
Micromania mais c'est peut-être bien ce
que je vais
[Musique]
faire bonjour je voudrais acheter des
jeux
vidéos
non mais sérieux vous voulez pas plutôt
acheter une figurine POP non non mais
vraiment je veux vraiment acheter des
jeux vidéos là par exemple ce jeu
d'occasion là combien il
coû bon ok vous avez gagné je vais
acheter mes jeux ici mais ce CCI vous
allez me filer des bons jeux des vrais
bons jeux ça fait 13 ans que je acheter
mes jeux ici merde et la boutique vous
remercie
ouais en fait à chaque fois vous me
vendez des jeux de merde quoi je vais
finir par croire
que c'est un complot quoi un
complot n'importe quoi c'est ça c'est
dans les films les
complotsentends ça car parle pas
imbécile non sérieusement il y a aucun
complot ici pas vrai les gars oui oui il
a raison il pas de complot ici prenez
plutôt ce carton que je touter vous m'
direz des nouvelles je suis sûr qu'ils
sont bien
ceux rig c'est votè de me chatouiller
arrêtez
ça allez qu'est-ce qu'on a là-dedans All
Star action e ben la sobriété de
cette jaquette quoi c'est vraiment juste
le titre en rouge et une image de
flancfou et oh c'est des jeux de
course et de sport j'ai oublié de dire
que j'aimais pas ça c'est encore du
phenix game merde allez il faut rester
positif je veux dire statistiquement ils
ont pas pu rater absolument tout ce
qu'ils ont fait attends attendsattends
c'est pas le moment où tu dis un truc et
c'est le contraire qui arrive
ok donc tous les jeux ont été fait par
une boîte de graphisme qui s'appelle ti
GFX et dont le logo est en comixant
c'est pas très rassurant premier jeu
reves un jeu de voiture alors nous avons
donc le nombre astronomique de
de courses différentes c'est cool parce
qu'après quand il y a trop de choix je
me sens
perdu on peut colore swap la voiture
c'est important pour savoir si vous
voulez vous emmerder en rouge en noir ou
en bleu et le jeu commence avec une
physique vraiment très réaliste et
débruitag et poustouflant
et c'est clairement aussi passionnant
pour moi que ça en a l'air pour vous ah
oh mais j'en peux plus de
ce son
pause bon alors on peut se dire oh ça va
ça ressemble à tous les jeux de cours de
la Playstation 1 alors oui ça ressemble
au jeux de cours de la Playstation 1
sorti en 1995 genre je veux dire ça
ressemble à rid Racer oui enfin sauf que
ça c'est sorti en 2003 hein la même
année que grand turourismo 4 prologue
mais vous voyez c'est pas grave parce
que finalement c'est pour ça que c'est
bien les compiles de jeu un mini jeu
n'est pas top pas grave il suffit de
lancer le jeu suivant et allez on a une
aventure complètement
[Musique]
différente oh oh oh 2 secondes là
c'est le même c'est le même son de
moteur la voiture c'est exactement la
même physique ça se joue pareil c'est le
même menu c'est les mêmes options y a
que la voiture qui change et vite fait
le nom des circuits Salo oh vous la
sentez venir la douille allez je suivant
top speed rally vous foutez de ma
gueule le même circuit il y a même plus
un effort de changer un truc je suivant
battle truck mais
ils ont juste changé le skin
voiture en skin de camion vous êtes ça
se pilote exactement pareil regardez la
miabilité de ce camion ça a aucun
de sens et comment tu défends ça au
tribunal en même temps le camion il y a
pas de remorque hein
donc à
quitter en plus c'est vraiment des
branleurs ils se sont même pas fait
chier à mettre un son un peu différent
pour donner l'illusion que c'est un
camion ah non non c'est le même son sur
tous les jeux allez jeu suivant super
bike GT c'est évidemment encore le même
circuit
attends je rêve ou je vais moins vite
avec la moto qu'avec le
camion ouais ah ils sont vraiment pas
bon hein bon ben voilà c'est fini pas
besoin de lancer le reste on sait que ça
va être la même merde tu peux pas dire
que tu as pas aimé si tu as pas fini en
entier c'est dire que j'ai pas besoin de
lécher tous les trottoirs du monde pour
savoir que j'aime pas ça un seul ça
suffit tu sais ce qu'on m'ofrait moi
quand j'étais petit à Noël de mon temps
on m'offrait des oranges et j'étais très
heureux parce que j'adore les
oranges de de quoi on parlait euh de
mauvais jeu ah d'accord tu as pas une
orange bizarre ok je suivant et
effectivement pas besoin de faire durer
ce suspense insoutenable c'est de la
merde en barquette voilà donc on a un
jeu de planche à voile surfing Paradise
si tu enlèves la voile ça fait un jeu de
surf ride the wave et si tu enlèves la
moitié du surf ça fait un jeu de
bodyboard extreme borders et c'est
strictement les mêmes jeux depuis le
bruit des menus jusqu'au nom des
personnages c'est garanti 100 % zéro
effort je peux choisir l'orange encore
bon bref donc comme j'ai dit vous pouvez
choisir votre personnage ça sert à rien
ou la couleur de la planche pareil sert
à rien il a pas de système de
caractéristiqu c'estd pas eu le temps
pour faire ça mais a plein de cartes
quand même effectivement c'est vrai le
jeu vous offre un vaste choix de cartes
vous avez
launabit c'est la
mer c'est aussi la mer San
Diego c'est toujours la mer et on se
fout de ta
gueule dire que que vous voyez pas la
différence parce que vous vous y connaz
rien au surf mais euh moi je planche à
voile planche à
voile allez qu'est-ce qu'on a d'autre
shoot sorti en 2003 oh le menu il
me fout la déprime déjà oh ça va encore
être une compile allez vas-y on prend le
premier Wild West
ouais bon ben ok he c'est un jeu où on
tire sur des trucs voilà vous avez vu
tout le jeu là bon en même temps le
machin il s'appelle shoot c'est fou
parce que je m'attendais à être déçu
mais j'ai quand même réussi à être plus
déçu que ce que je pensais bon ben j'ai
pas besoin de vous expliquer le principe
hein ça s'appelle shoot donc ça va être
un jeu où on shoot des gens grosse
imagination pour le titre encore une
fois bon comment pourrait-on appeler
notre jeu de
shoot shoot qui a dit
ça mais c'est génial je vous donne
directeur mais monsieur c'est vous le
directeur je suis le directeur je suis
le
directeur je vous jure on dirait
que c'est chiant exprès à chaque fois
que je veux changer de jeu je dois
bouger mon gros cul jusqu'à la console
pour reset parce qu'ils ont pas prévu de
boutons pour quitter dans les menus bref
allez jeu suivant
warones un jeu où on pilote des
vaisseaux
ok on s'emmerde je suivant space
rbellion il y a un problème de son là
non et ta sœur c'est reparti comme pour
la compile d'avant c'est exactement
pareil allez je suivant if22 oh mais
vous vous foutez de ma gueule je suivant
r rescue il y a un hélicoptère sur
l'écran de chargement et vous vous
foutez de ma gueule et regardez moi
aussi je peux le
faire connard alle c'est bon je change
de jeu plein le cul des compiles flying
Squadron sur PS1 mais put c'est le même
jeu le de même jeu de merde vendu
à l'unité sous un autre
nom
merde je suis 20 wanted
vour
[Musique]
suivant enfin du
mais je vais pleurer c'est juste la même
chose encore c'est le même de jeu
avec un skin différent les enemis sont
les mêmes on est dans le futur et on
affronte soit siège je change de jeu et
de console comme ça ça mieux
sérieusement de
bordel ils ont refait un nouveau moteur
graphique pour faire la
même
allez il y a même pas
de il y a même pas de sniper dans ce jeu
qui s'appelle sniper assaut que vous
pourriez ne pas me prendre pour un con
pant que vous m'enculez c'est trop
demandé je vous jure j'ai passé plus de
temps à me lever pour aller changer de
jeu qu'à jouer au jeux eux-mêmes c'est
incroyable d'avoir aussi peu de
considération pour son métier parfois
quand on change de jeu les développeurs
n'ont même pas pris la peine de changer
les noms des personnages dans les high
SCOR tellement ils s'en foutent et pour
vous dire parfois il n'y a même pas le
titre du jeu affiché dans le jeu
histoire que ça soit plus rapide à
revendre sous un autre nom attendez
est-ce que c'est pas juste les plus gros
arnaqueurs du monde sincèrement je va
dire attends
voilà hamster ball quel est ce degré
d'arnaque voilà c'est comme mon Ky mais
c'est pas un singe c'est un hamster
voilà rien à voir speed machine qui est
autorisé pour les nouveaunés d'ailleurs
un jeu où vous contrôlez des petites
voitures
jouées ça vous rappelle quelque chose
c'est sûrement le hasard des fois il
s'emmerd même plus à changer le nom par
exemple combat Ace ah parce que ça n'est
pas Ace Combat le jeu d'avion c'est
combat Ace le je avion ça n'a rien à
voir ah ici on a la flemme de réfléchir
on va pas se faire chier on acore pomper
des vieux titres tenez voilà rétro8
classique regardez comment ça Pac-Man
mais non ça n'est pas Pac-Man c'est
gobler et ça ça n'est pas puzzle bbble
c'est bubble puzzle et ça ça n'est pas
astéroïde c'est attends merde on peut
pas inverser les mots là il y en a qu'un
comment on fait ah ben voilà c'est Roids
sérieusement ils en sont juste à enlever
des syllabes maintenant et oui ça aura
été ça la vie de Phenix Games une série
ininterrompu d'arnaque jeu de sport jeu
d'avion jeu de tir plagiaat de Disney et
les terrifiants jeux du siverse histoire
d'essayer également de dépouiller les
petites filles de leur argent de poche
alors c'est très difficile de trouver
des infos sur Phoenix game parce que et
bien leur business Modelle tout entier
étit basé sur l'arnaque hein c'est des
voleurs purement et simplement donc
forcément ils allaient pas le crier sur
les toits mais vraiment la question que
je me pose c'est comment ils ont fait
pour faire des jeux jusqu'à l'époque de
la Wii sans que les avocats de Disney
leur tombent dessus avocat Disney
compagnie ouvrez la
porte oui nous avons un mandat pour
fouiller les
lieux attendez un instant s'il vous
[Musique]
plaît je suis Nar mon frère vous êtes
dans une église et c'est un lieu de
recueillement vous ne pouvez pas rentrer
ah oui et quel Liu vous
priezah le bon nous avons aussi un
mandat pour fouiller les églises
ok attendez une minute
[Applaudissements]
ouais désolé on est en plein Amam là ça
sera pas possible pour nous il des gens
tout nus vous pourvez pas fouiller
désolé wou ils sont forts les
jeux phennix étaient souvent vendus dans
des stations service ou des petits
commerces à bas prix et tiré à très peu
d'exemplaires ce qui paradoxalement
aujourd'hui les rang très dur à trouver
et surtout très cher cette merde là
cette grosse merde 500 balles 500 balles
ok là il faut qu'on parle tu vas me dire
pourquoi tu me refiles toujours des jeux
pourris je vais tout vous dire
ok pourquoi tu parles pas mais je
[Musique]
dire la
vérité que vous faites bien je suis
actuellement en train de me
suicider une partie de moi elle savait
la vérité c'est que vous pouvez un peu
me décaler sur la gauche merci ok la
vérité
c'est merde il a été
assassiné modit point rouge prends ça
merurtrier mais la la source je cherche
la source
[Musique]
vous vous avez vu quelque
chose pas très sympa les clients par
mais ah mais mais c'est lui mais
poursuis-le il est
là ah désolé je vous ai confondu à
quelqu autre problème
[Musique]
dude et merde c'est foutu il a
disparu
[Musique]
oh mais c'est un fond vert là on
avait dit un fond bleu oh vas-y je me
casse je suis Tinky Winky grand consul
de la flamme bleue bienvenue à toi cul
de feu cul de ATT attendez quoi oui car
comme tu t'en doutais au fond de toi il
y a bel et bien une raison au fait que
tu ne testes que des jeux de merde en
réalité la solution était sous toi ton
canapé n'est pas un simple canapé il est
relié à une batterie qui alimente la
chaleur du soleil c'est ça ton cul
génère une chaleur de 400 de cvin par
seconde ce qui est plus qu'un mortel
ordinaire grâce à la chaleur de ton cul
nous contrôlons et régulons le climat du
système tout entier regarde comme le
bébé a l'air heureux
et pourquoi on n jamais vu la tête du
bébé dans le soleil nous ça c'est parce
que notre planète se situe de l'autre
côté du soleil par rapport à la Terre en
fait nous d'ici on voit la tête mais
vous vous voyez que ses faesses en
permanence regardez-le dans ce
télescope et quel rapport avec les
mauvais jeux et bien plus ton cul est en
contact avec le canapé plus le soleil
chauffe or dernièrement la difficulté
croissante des jeux auquels tu as joué
t'a poussé à rester assis trop longemps
cette réaction a entraîné un
réchauffement climatique d'une ampleur
sans précédent attendez une seconde le
réchauffement climatique c'est pas
plutôt dur à la surconsommation à la
pollution les usines ah non non on a
vérifié c'est vraiment que votre cul ben
ouais regardez le schéma là les 99%
c'est votre cul il a vraiment aucun
doute et 1% restant c'est les gens qui
ét une
Lesur mais du coup ça veut dire que si
je change de
canapé
[Musique]
et c'est pour ça que je voudrais faire
changer mon
canapé monsieur c'est une bibliothèque
ici
ah du coup du coup c'est
non ça explique pas du tout pourquoi tu
es assis par terre et il est où le
canapé maintenant j'ai oublié la
bibliothèque
[Musique]